wir müssen reden und wir wollen reden
denn wir sind hier in Dubai hier findet
eine weltklim Konferenz ST statt in
einem
erdölstaat und da kriegt man schon so
ein bisschen das Gefühl hä was soll denn
das ist das macht das wirklich Sinn
macht man da nicht den Drogendealer zum
entzugshelfer und golineatai du kennst
diese Region wie nur wenige du
berichtest aus dem arabischen Raum
kannst du uns erklären ob das jetzt
wirklich so eine sinnige ist ja für die
Region selber ist es natürlich eine sehr
sinnige Sache für die Emirate denn sie
zwingen die Welt mit ihnen zu reden sie
sagen schaut auf uns ihr müsst die Öl-
und Gasindustrie an Bord holen wir haben
das ja aktiv mit der Kop 28 getan wir
nehmen sie als aktiver Ansprechpartner
an Bord und ihr habt ihr müsst die
Möglichkeit nutzen dass die
Klimabewegung dass die Politik mit der
Öl- und Gasindustrie in Kontakt kommt
und auß erd dem kann man uns auf der
Weltkarte überhaupt nicht mehr übersehen
wir sind das Singapur des Nahen Ostens
wir sind die Aufstreben der Weltregion
wir sind ein regionaler handelshub wir
sind aber auch ein weltweiter handelshub
wir sind jemand mit dem ihr rechnen
müsst wir haben mit durch unsere
Staatsfonds sehr viel Kapital dass wir
auch bei euch investieren auch in euren
Häfen sind wir da und wir werden immer
präsenter werden und
wir profitieren von den vielen vielen
Krisen die es gerade gibt weil wir uns
sehr gut aufgestellt haben weil wir
quasi diese globale Tektonik die sich
jetzt neu entwickelt ums Schiffen auf
der Suche nach immer neuen Partnern und
wir haben von diesen Krisen profitiert
also fast 6% Wirtschaftswachstum letztes
Jahr im nichtölsektor das ist traubhaft
für uns das kann sich eigentlich keiner
vorstellen also die Dynamik die man hier
sieht die ist eine Dynamik die wirklich
die wirklich angeschaut werden muss und
die man nicht übersehen können ist auch
eine verrückte Dynamik oder ich meine du
kommst hier an und denkst das ist doch
der du kommst hier an verrückte Dynamik
du denkst es ist doch wirklich der der
Irrsinn des erdölzeitalters diese
Verschwendung von Energie Wasser dieser
wahnsinnige
Beton ja Stadt das ist das ist das der
richtige Weg ist das
Zukunft ich hoffe nicht dass das die
Zukunft ist weil man kann ja sagen dass
Dubai eigentlich
genau das Gegenteil von nachhaltigem
Städtebau ist also ist eigentlich
praktisch das Schlimmste Gegenmodell das
ich mir vorstellen kann ich bin das
erste Mal in Dubai und sehe das hier
wenn wir so weltweit bauen würden dann
würden wir relativ schnell auf einen
globalen Albtraum zusteuern auf dem wir
ja sowieso schon zusteuern aber der wird
dann noch
schlimmer ich denke das ist aber nicht
das worum es hier geht ich selber
empfinde das als ja deutsche
Journalistin die hier so rum läuft ich
versuche möglichst zu vielen
Veranstaltungen zu gehen viele Eindrücke
zu bekommen als eine interessante
Perspektive die man hier bekommt nämlich
vor allem dadurch dass man so viele
verschiedene Perspektiven bekommen und
das macht glaube ich auch das
Interessante an dieser Veranstaltung aus
ähm wir haben hier nicht
reggierungsorganisationen wir haben hier
Regierungen die hier vertreten sind wir
haben hier die Wirtschaft die da ist und
die hat ja auch eine Schlüsselstellung
ja also Klimawandel Klimaschutz ist
nicht eine Sache von irgendwelchen Ökos
mehr sondern das ist ja eine Sache die
vor allem die Wirtschaft auch
vorantreiben muss und wir sehen
natürlich dass wir Europäer hier längst
mit unserer Perspektive in den
Hintergrund geraten also wenn ich hier
ich war gestern Abend auf einer ganz
interessanten Veranstaltung da waren
wirklich Menschen aus aller Welt und da
kam ein Kenianer auf mich zu und sagte
ich will jetzt mal erzählen wie unsere
Perspektive ist wir im globalen Süden
wir müssen selber bestimmen darüber wie
es vorangeht wir lassen uns nicht länger
von euch diktieren die ihr diese Welt am
meisten im Prinzip in Mitleidenschaft
gezogen habt und ausgebeutet habt wir
lassen uns von euch nicht länger
diktieren wie es vorangeht wir werden
selber ein Wort mit ren und das ist doch
interessant dass man diese Perspektiven
sieht ja die Rolle ich glaub das ist das
was was die Rolle dass wir in Europa uns
immer noch als Vorreiter sehen was
teilweise auch stimmmen man ursela von
der Lein kam hier gestern vorgestern mit
breiter Brust und erklärte was wir alles
tun das stimmt natürlich aber das ist
auch ein bisschen so der moraline
Zeigefinger und das das ist e das Gefühl
das kommt gar nicht gut an nee nee das
ist äh da kommt dann gleich wieder die
Keule mit der Doppelmoral und mit den
Doppelstandards die dann ausgefahren
wird ähm ich ich erlebe in meinen
Gesprächen oft dass man sagt wir hier
sind doch in einer viel viel besseren
und authentischeren Stellung als ihr wir
haben so gute so nahe Kontakte zu Afrika
ähm wir haben hier die die
Privatwirtschaft ganz eng wirklich an
uns gebunden weil das ist die das ist
der Zweig der wirklich den den
Klimawandel begreifen und die
Energiewende realisieren muss und
wir sehen uns hier auch als globaler
Süden oder auch als Fürsprecher dieser
dieser Länder also wir können viele Pole
miteinander verbinden und das könnt ihr
nicht dafür habt ihr nicht die
Authentizität ja was ich spannend finde
da würde mich mal deine Perspektive
interessieren der den Blick jetzt auf
sag mal auch die Ziele und die Umsetzung
hat was bringt denn der
äh sogenannte globale Süden insofern man
das überhaupt so verallgemeinern kann
was bringt denn der ein also kann man so
das so schwarz-weiß sagen hier ist ein
böser Ölstaat
und dort sind die guten Europäer also
was was kommen denn für Impulse die du
hier auch siehst also erstmal kommt viel
Geld was man teilweise überhaupt nicht
versteht da werden Milliarden in diesen
Fond und climate finance hier und das
sind unglaublich ja sophisticated also
kom erte Regelwerke die da dran hängen
und da durchzusteigen ist wirklich
schwierig aber da wird natürlich viel
Geld versprochen und Geld ist was der
globale Süden natürlich sucht die sagen
das ist euer Problem ihr habt's
verursacht zu großen Teilen ein
Kühlschrank in Amerika noch immer mehr
Energieverbrauch als ein Mensch im
Senegal z.B ja sollte ich die sagen so
ist euer Ding ihr habt das verursacht
wir wir müssen uns helfen und wenn da
was kommt dann ist das was auf der
anderen Seite haben wir was gesehen
auch hier die Emirate kaufen ganze
Waldbestände 10% 20% der Wälder in
Simbabwe und machen da riesen um sich
hier sozusagen ihr CO2 schön zu rechnen
das ist so ein bisschen Carbon
colonialism ne also Kohlenstoff
kolonalismus und da ist das auch sehr
ambivalent das Verhältnis und ich glaube
Europa tut sich schwer damit zu
akzeptieren dass wir jetzt mit der
Pferdekutsche nicht um die Ecke kommen
können wir können nicht sagen ihr ihr
ihr der Reichtum hier der begründet sich
doch auf all dem was hier im Boden liegt
das lassen die sich nicht einfach nehmen
die wollen weiter Geld verdienen aber
wollen noch auch
umbauen Weiterkommen auch im mit grünen
Wasserstoff aber sie wollen natürlich
weiterhin Geld verdienen sagen so wir
hören jetzt auf damit und machen die
alles wieder dicht machen die Hotels zu
machen das Wasser weg und und gehen
wieder zurück so wird's nicht laufen und
deswegen ohne die wird's nicht laufen
und hier zeigt sich dann dieses Dilemma
wir hängen an diesem Tropf wir wollen
davon men das geht nur mit denen und das
wird hier direkt vor Augen wir können
das gerne in Stockholm machen unds
allees schön reden auch wie wie
heiterteil wir sind in Europa aber hier
wird halt gesagt das Dilemma der Welt
und das ist zu lösen und das tut weh
wenn wir jetzt auf die ersten Tage der
Weltklimakonferenz schauen also das
Thema Ambition und Vision ist ja hier
immer ganz groß und da ist tatsächlich
auch der Wille zu verspüren bei den
Emiratis dass Sie wirklich wollen dass
das eine erfolgreiche Kop wird die
ersten Tage waren ja
schon und starker Aufschlag würde ich
sagen oder wie siehst du das die sind
clever die haben ein Team
zusammengestellt aus ganz erfahrenen
internationalen ihren eigenen Leuten
aber auch internationalen Managern man
der koppräsident Sultan aljaber ist ein
gewiefter Manager aus der Branche die
machen die wissen wie man PR macht die
kommen hier BAM gerade rein mit wir
haben noch nie sowas gemacht einen
Durchbruch eine Entscheidung am ersten
Tag ein klimafond einen schutzfond
aufgesetzt für die Ärmsten das macht
natürlich Eindruck da haben z ersten Mal
die Emiratis auch Geld einbezahlt die ja
klassisch noch als Entwicklungsland
gelten diese vor 30 Jahren getroffener
Einteilung der UNO die auch eine
interessante Kategorie Entwicklungsland
ja die entwickeln sich aber wie viel
1000 do$ar mehr pro Kopf glaube ich
selbst als wir in Deutschland das
Einkommen also das ist ja verrückt und
die sagen die machen hier ein Aufschlag
und beeindrucken damit die Kritiker
sagen natürlich die lenken ab davon dass
sie weiter Öl und Gas verkaufen wollen
und das ist ja der der Knackpunkt wenn
wir es nicht schaffen von Öl Gas
wegzukommen dann wird das nichts mit
1,5° Ziel dann dann dann versemmeln wir
das ganz und das ist sozusagen
Ablenkungsmanöver ob das dem gerecht
wird ist so unglaublich schwierig ja es
ist so schwierig wie die Menschen hier
einzuschätzen die sind ja Händler und ja
halten sie auch ihre Karten bedeckt klar
und das wird sich jetzt zeigen also es
gibt unterschiedliche Widersprüche
Signale fragt man die Umwelt die
deutschen Umweltverbände die laufen Amok
und dann gibt's sie die sagen vielleicht
tut sich da was weil wer kennt die
Saudis besser als dieser koppräsident
wer hat den Einfluss in die OPEC wer
kann da was bewegen das ist dieses
dieses Spannungsfeld das kann man nicht
einfach aber und da von Europa zu sagen
nee so geht das nicht Leute keine Chance
es ist ja auch längst nicht mehr so dass
man die Welt in
diese globalen Felder einteilen kann wie
wir das man nicht mal tun also als ob
Europa nun den der große Vorreiter ist
und wir das alles sag mal mal
widerspruchslos hinnehmen was hier
passieren muss auch mit den
begleiterscheidungen des Verzichts und
wachstumsverzichts tun wir ja nicht ich
meine in Deutschland führen wir die
Debatte darum und da heißt es dann
müssen wir im Winter frieren das ist ja
absurd wenn man sich mal anguckt was der
Rest der Welt erlebt
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir
Länder die sagen ja wir investieren auch
in grüne Energie ich meine Saudi-Arabien
oder auch hier die Emirate sind ja
Länder die nicht nur in fossile
Brennstoff investieren und das Ausbauen
sondern gleichzeitig auch in grüne
Energie und ich denke man muss den Blick
öffnen und gucken was passiert wo
anstatt einfach so grobe schlaglinien zu
machen weil sonst kommen wir nicht
weiter mm und ich glaube es ist für uns
auch noch mal besonders schwierig
sich in den anderen hinein zu versetzen
also dieses mindset hier zu verstehen
und ich glaub dafür sind wir alle auch
hier um dieses mindset begreifbar zu
machen ich habe vergangene Woche
ein ein Dreh gehabt bei einem der
größten Solarprojekte weltweit ein
Solarpark der gerade von Masta eröffnet
wurde Sultan hier in in den Emiraten bei
Abu Dhabi und Massa das ist diese Firma
die auch von sultanja geleitet wird ist
ja nicht nur head of oil
hier des größten lkonzerns des
staatlichen Ölkonzerns sondern eben auch
der erneuerbaren Energien und ich fand
zwei Dinge ganz interessant zum einen
diese selbstvision von wie sind die
Quelle Master bedeutet auf Arabisch
Quelle also wir sind diejenigen die noch
Jahrzehnte vielleicht auch sogar noch
Jahrhunderte Energie in welcher Form
auch immer exportieren werden nicht nur
Energie als Energie sondern auch Energie
als
kno-how der Chief Operating Officer der
der Betriebsleiter hat mir erzählt dass
er gerade aus Usbekistan zurückgekommen
ist und dort baut Master sehr sehr
fleißig Wind und Solarparks
aber es ist eben nicht nur so dass dort
Wind und Solarparks von den Emiratis
gebaut werden sondern es gibt auch ein
Unternehmen das mit MDA verbandelt ist
und dort eben Gaskraftwerke baut oder
Gaskraftwerke erweitert also man man
versucht quasi auch diese Länder in
seinen eigenen Radius zu holen und von
sich abhängig zu machen in ganz
verschiedener Form wir ja auch
janusköpfig sozusagen aber wir ja auch
in Deutschland wir ja auch ich mE wir
bauen Gas wir Brückentechnologien wir
schließen Verträge
wir kriechen teilweise dann auch zu
Kreuze das ist natürlich eine Folge des
ukrainekriegs klar das hat natürlich
vieles verändert und das ist auch kein
Vorwurf glaube ich wie wie wie Politik
da regieren muss aber wir haben ja genau
das auch wir sind ja wir sind ja nicht
die die die guten die die nur das Gute
tun wir haben gute Absichten und keine
Frage aber wir müssen ja genauso sehen
wo unsere Energie und das war ja auch
das was du gesagt hast ist
heizungsgesetz ja Tempolimit wie schwer
wir uns tun selbst beim Sparen ja
vielleicht auf dem anderen Niveau sind
anders wo vielleicht wirklich in der
Lage Dinge schon zu tun die uns
einfacher fallen gut wir haben auch kein
Erdöl was wir verkaufen ne wir müssen es
ist ja so ein bisschen die Biografie die
anders ist die Geschichte des Landes es
ist ein unglaublich junges Land wie alle
golfmonarchien
ähm ich fand es ganz interessant bei der
Eröffnung dass der Urvater der
Gründungsvater als Hologramm quasi auf
die Bühne geholt wurde und sich alles
auf ihn so projiziert hat ähm ein junges
Land und ich ich war sehr ich ich bin
wirklich ins denken gekommen als dieser
Manager da im Solarpark weiter erzählt
hat und gesagt hat ja wenn man sich so
den Lauf der Welt anschaut so wie unser
Land sich entwickelt hat also meine
Mutter die hatte keine Toilette bei sich
im Haus die musste erstmal rausgehen
mein Vater war ungebildet er hat sein
Schulabschluss erst gemacht als mein
Bruder in der sechsten Klasse war und
meine Mutter ist heute die Queen of
Social Media und leitet ihre
whatsapp-gruppe und das waren so Worte
die wirklich bei mir nachheil gefunden
haben wo ich gedacht habe okay das muss
man erstmal jetzt begreifen das ist die
neue Generation die nicht dahin
zurückkehren möchte wo die Eltern einst
waren das heißt ich kann nicht von denen
verlangen dass das Umdenken von heute
auf morgen stattfindet irgendwie und das
ist ein entwickelter Staat des globalen
Südens gucken wir mal nach
Afrika da haben wir es mit Ländern zu
tun die sagen wir haben bis jetzt
überhaupt kein an der globalen
Umweltverschmutzung es gibt nur ein Land
in mit Südafrika das überhaupt
Kohlekraftwerke betreibt ganzen
Kontinent muss man muss man wir haben
die Entwicklung noch vor uns wollt ihr
das weiter unsere
Menschen keine Entwicklung haben wir
wollen unsere Kinder zur Schule schicken
wir wollen auch Kühlschränke wir möchten
auch Entwicklung und wie soll diese
Entwicklung möglich sein ich glaube das
ist eine eine Kernfrage die wir nicht
unbeantwortet lassen dürfen und
können weil das Problem Klimawandel das
ganze Drama das damit verbunden ist
können wir nur global lösen und wenn wir
die Länder nicht mitnehmen und ich würde
da jetzt auch nicht mehr so
verallgemeinert sagen der globale Süden
weil auch der globale Süden hat große
Unterschiede ja 90% erneuerbare Energien
hätten wir gerne als ich das zum ersten
Mal gehört habe dachte ich das das
widerspricht so vielen Klischees in
meinem Kopf ja genau und die treten sehr
selbstbewusst aus also wenn wenn man
hier gerade mit Afrikanern spricht ähm
die haben mir z.B als Deutscher
Journalistin ich war gestern Abend bei
so einer Veranstaltung war da waren sehr
viele Afrikaner mit großem
Selbstbewusstsein gesagt nain wir lassen
uns das von euch nicht diktieren wir
wissen auch ganz genau was in Europa für
Diskussionen geführt wird was wollt ihr
wollt ihr weiter dass unsere Menschen
hier auf dem Null stand bleiben guck
doch einfach mal was für Entwicklung
stattfindet und ein zweiter glaube ich
sehr wichtiger Aspekt
ist dass Länder wie z.B auch Brasilien
zeigen oder auch fordern was ja jetzt
Lula das silver getan hat mit dem
Regenwald die sagen es gibt bestimmte
Zonen der Erde wie der Regenwald die
sind für das globale Klima und nicht nur
für für für für Lateinamerika zuständig
und da muss auch die Welt ihren Anteil
tragen das find ich ein sehr
interessanten Aspekt ich war mal in
Brasilien hat mir einer erklärt wo ist
den euer Regenwald eigentlichen hattet
ihr in Europa was haben ihr damit
gemacht ach verfeuert interessant ja
gerodet ja warum dürfen wir das nicht
aber was machen wir was machen wir da
wie wie kommen wir da zu einer Lösung
ist es eine Lösung z.B jetzt zu
sagen wir kaufen den regenbald auf ja
das macht blue Carbon hier das ist das
was sie wirklich das ist ist eine Lösung
die Umweltschützer sind sehr sehr
skeptisch ja weil es ein bisschen so
green wasashing Verdacht hat ne ich
kaufe da wie auch ne Carbon capture and
storage also hier versuchen die die
Ölindustrie klimaneutral zu machen
irgendwann wird's doch verbrannt das ist
da da ist man sehr sehr skeptisch aber
vielleicht auch skeptisch weil man es
nicht versteht ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich bin da unentschlossen weil ich
ich ich das ist mir zu einfach zu sagen
das sind immer die bösen die machen da
bös haben eine böse Absicht vielleicht
funktioniert das nicht immer aber so
vieles funktioniert auch bei uns nicht
in diesem Bereich ja wenn wir aber ich
glaube das ist zu einfach aber das ist
da habe ich da kann ich das ist schwer
sich darum Reim zu machen ja
aber aber es passiert halt was und das
ist und das glaub ich haben auch viele
gesagt ich weiß nicht auch die die
vielen Cops waren die Stimmung hier ist
alle wollen was machen und alle haben
das Problem erkannt die Restriktionen
gehen damit nicht weg die Probleme ob
bei uns zu Hause ob in den Ländern
selbst aber der Spirit ist einer das
zumindest was vorwärts gebracht werden
kann geht das schnell genug ich habe
auch das Gefühl dass die Welt sich
Moment an einem Punkt befindet das dafür
ist natürlich nicht nur der dramatische
Klimawandel sondern auch die Kriege eine
der
Ursachen dass wir wissen wir müssen
handeln also ich glaube das Wissen darum
dass wir etwas tun müssen war noch nie
so breit gestreut es ist verbunden mit
großer Depression und sicherlich auch
einem Stück weit Hoffnungslosigkeit und
viele Menschen sehen die Lage sehr sehr
negativ aber auch trotzdem mit der
Erkenntnis wenn wir jetzt nicht etwas
tun und dem Einhalt gebieten dann wird's
noch schlimmer und ich glaube so nah
waren wir an dieser Erkenntnis noch nie
das ist das was mir so ein bisschen
Hoffnung macht zeigt ja auch deiner
ostkonflikt was hat man vorher gerätselt
wird es vielleicht sogar abgesagt wegen
dem was dort passiert war vielleicht ein
bisschen over the top aber spielt
eigentlich nicht so eine Rolle oder also
jeden den man so trifft sorry ist
wichtig ist eine Tragödie wir haben
unsere Standpunkte aber hier geht's um
was Größeres es gab ein Bild das glaube
ich prägend war oder so ein
zeichengesetz
hat als Israels Präsident Herzog hier
angekommen ist und zum ersten Mal glaube
ich dem katarischen emia tanim die Hand
gegeben hat
und das das ist glaube ich so das wird
auch eines der Bilder sein die in die
Geschichte eingehen werden ich komme
wieder zu unserem mindset dass wir über
diese Region haben und besonders über
dieses Land Qatar wo wir ja sagen oh
Gott das ist wieder ein ganz böses Land
von dem wir uns abhängig machen und wir
haben ja schon gesehen wie das bei der
Fußball WM gelaufen ist und äh
ähm wir müssen da ganz aufpassen aber
wir müssen tatsächlich mit mit einem
nüchternen Realismus da glaube ich auch
drauf schauen was was ist denn da
eigentlich die Rolle von von Qatar und
wie kommt dieser Handschlag Zustande
sicher Qatar ist ein Land
das Terror finanziert hat auf jeden Fall
dass die hamasführung beherbergt hat wir
müssen aber auch uns anschauen die
massführung ist auch auf Bitten der USA
in Qatar beherbergt worden damit damit
man sie besser kontrollieren kann wenn
sie in Damaskus genau no your enemies B
them also wenn sie in Damaskus geblieben
wären wenn sie in bairut oder plötzlich
in den Iran gegangen werden was was wäre
dann passiert ne und man muss auch sagen
okay es ist es gibt jetzt kein leider
keinen waffenschirstand mehr aber
tatsächlich war Katar einer der ganz
großen treibenden Kräfte neben Ägypten
die eben sehr viel möglich gemacht haben
und ich glaube so diese diese Dynamik
die geht bei unser Bewertungen und auch
in unseren Schlagzeilen sehr oft unter
dass man eben auf das ganze Bild schauen
muss auf ein Katar das ein eines der
größten US Militärbasen im Persischen
Golf beherwerkt und insgesamt so
bisschen auch das Gefühl dass wir so in
den arabischen Raum immer so in in eine
ein eine Stanze pressen und dann wird
hier das israelische Fernsehen hoffiert
ich das war auch wirklich
so bist doch im arabischen aber nein ist
hier wissen wir z.B dass es hier
eine eine Synagoge gibt und dass es die
erste Synagoge ist die ich glaub nach
100 Jahren auf arabischem Raum neu
gebaut wurde in einem super
interessanten kulturell
architektonischen
Komplex mit einer Moschee drin mit einer
Kirche drin und dass diese Synagoge
durchaus eine spirituelle und auch große
Bedeutung hat auch für die Juden
weltweit also das ist das finde ich
total faszinierend aber das sind so
Bilder die wei ich die tauchen bei uns
nicht an erster Stelle auf wenn wir eben
über diese
nachdenken ich glaube aber der dieser
Aspekt des differenzierten Denkens und
des genau
Hinschauens das ist vielleicht auch
etwas dass man mal im Hinblick auf eine
Lösung und das was bei dieser Kop jetzt
hier rauskommen kann soll wird im
Hinterkopf haben muss weil was das Thema
Klimawandel Klimaschutz angeht die
Rettung der Welt denken wir immer in den
ganz großen Lösungen oder die sind ja
auch nötig aber sie sind sind eben nicht
möglich das haben wir ja nun wirklich
gelernt ja Trippelschritte ja es sind ja
vielleicht auf der einen Seite
Trippelschritte aber es sind auch glaube
ich die Schritte die in so vielen
verschiedenen Richtungen stattfinden
also wenn man mal genau hinguckt was ist
z.B für Initiativen
gibt wo die stattfinden wo Schutzräume
eingerichtet werden kann man sagen okay
ja das das ist jetzt nicht viel aber
letztendlich was nutzen große
Erklärungen dass wir uns verpflichten
ähäh die und die Klimaziele einzuhalten
wenn sie doch nicht eingehalten werden
also ich glaube die konkreten
Initiativen das konkrete Handeln dass
ich sehen kann da wo was passiert das
ist doch das woran sich diese Kop messen
lassen muss das sagen die Chinesen ja
immer so nett ja wir unterschreiben nur
Dinge die wir auch umsetzen können ein
bisschen mit dem Blick nach Amerika ja
wo vieles oder auch Europa wo vieles
unterschrieben wird und dann hinterher
wie kriegen wir das jetzt hin ne es ist
schon berechtigt mhm m ja ich meine das
es ist halt es bleibt natürlich für
viele diese dieser Spagat den das hier
abzunehmen dass ist ernst meinen ich
glaube da kann man das kann man nicht
weg diskutieren
aber die die Grundstimmung zu sagen wir
gehen weiter das ist positiv aber die
andere Frage ist natürlich wir haben
halt keine Zeit also das ist was
natürlich vor allem die Wissenschaft
bewegt also wenn man mit WIS ich habe im
Vorfeld der Kop wirklich mit
Wissenschaftler Wissenschaftlerinnen
also Leute die die da halt drin stecken
in diesem Klimawandel die die wirklich
die die Daten kennen die das Sehen und
und und und die da mit ganz anderen
Herzblut drin sind und und und die sagen
halt ja aber diese Zeit für für lassen
wir die jetzt mal mitkommen und wir
müssen die haben wir halt nicht mehr und
und wir haben in diesem Jahr gesehen und
ich und ich hatte hab auch das Gefühl
dass es in vielen anderen hier Ländern
auch angekommen ist Temperaturrekorde
58° in in in in in Mexiko in die die du
konntest ja teilweise in in die hier wie
der Golf von Mexico hatte hatte whpool
Temperatur und solche Sachen also der
das rückt noch mal näher und und und da
glaube ich kommt dann diese Frustration
auch her und wenn man dann dann so ein
Land wie Dubai da irgendwie hinsetzt
oder wie die Emirate und das in Dubai
stattfinden lässt und setzt sie da oben
drauf dann dann dann dann dann können
die das nicht fassen ja weil das passt
dann nicht weil sie sagen wir haben
jetzt keine Zeit noch auf deren
Befindlichkeiten in anführungszein oder
insgesamt auf die Befindlichkeit
Rücksicht zu nehmen und das macht's
glaube ich so so schwierig dann aus aus
der Sicht auch der Zivilgesellschaft die
natürlich hier dann noch sagt ja
Menschenrechte und Versammlungsfreiheit
auch schwierig völlig richtig ich kann
den Frust auch verstehen und ich glaube
jeder von uns der sich auch nur ein
bisschen in dieses Thema
eindenkt ja sieht einfach diese
verzweifelte Situation in der sich die
Erde befindet aber letztendlich werden
wir es nur global lösen können
und wir müssen alle Länder mitnehmen die
Wissenschaftler sind wichtig sind
Impulsgeber die Umweltbewegungen sind
finde ich extrem wichtig und ich habe
auch große Probleme damit wie sie
teilweise diskreditiert werden also ich
meine dass in Deutschland z.B
klimakleber praktisch als Terroristen
bezeichnet werden damit habe ich
wirklich ein großes Problem das sind
einfach Leute die eine Form von zivilen
Protest ausüben der vielleicht sehr
unangenehm und manchmal auch nicht so
ganz appropriate ist aber trotzdem ist
das ziviler Protest die töten keine
Menschen die beschmeißen auch nicht
Polizisten jetzt mit Messern oder so
sondern die kleben sich irgendwo hin und
haben ja damit auch ein bisschen Zug in
die Debatte gebracht vielleicht auch
negativen aber wir müssen darüber
debattieren wie können wir es umsetzen
und alle diese verschiedenen Teile mit
ins Boot holen und das Positive ich
versuche immer irgendwie auch ein
bisschen positiven Blick darauf zu
behalten
wir sehen ja gerade an den Kriegen die
wir jetzt im Moment haben was das
Scheitern internationaler Institut
wie der UN bedeutet das ist der
schlimmste Fall für die Erde und hier
haben wir das Gegenteil hier kommen doch
sehr viele Länder zusammen hier ist ja
selbst was Klimawandel und Umweltschutz
angeht kommittet sich ja selbst ein Land
wie Russland interessanterweise die sind
ja trotz all der Differenzen bei
bestimmten Zielen auch mit im Boot und
darauf müssen wir setzen dass die
Weltgemeinschaft und mit der
Weltgemeinschaft die verschiedenen
Aspekte Wirtschaft Zivilgesellschaft
Politik suchen zu einer Lösung zu kommen
gibt's den hier aber nicht so eine
Zivilgesellschaft das muss man sagen und
und und dass hier sozusagen ist den den
den den traditionell auf den
kopfveranstaltung sehr starken
Zivilgesellschaft den Aktivisten
AktivistInnen ist sehr schwer gemacht
wird hier man darf ja nur protestieren
eigentlich auf diesem un-kampus hier das
das das passt nicht ins Weltbild oder
absolut das ist ja vergangenes Jahr bei
der Cop 27 auch so gewesen dass es
wirklich reduziert wurde in Ägypten
genau und und ich weiß nicht hast du
diese Fläche gesehen ich habe die jetzt
noch nicht gesehen man demonstrieren
darf es ist überschaubar es ist nicht
hingehen und
testen es ist nicht das was die was sag
wir mal was man aus Europa vielleicht
gewohnt ist manchmal schlägt das ja dann
auch in in in in sehr unangenehme aber
ist halt eine andere aber damit könnt
ihr nichts anfangen und vor allen Dingen
ich frage mich auch wie wie läuft das
spontan weil gerade viele aus dieser
Bewegung z.B Zelten oder einfach
andere andere Formen des des des
Aufenthaltes ja ausprobieren hier ist
alles wahnsinnig teuer wir wir sind im
Industriegebiet gelandet im Hotel ich
weiß nicht wo die Leute hier unterkommen
und wie wie man das überhaupt finanziell
auf die Reihe bekommt das eines der
teuersten Länder der Welt auch ja wir
haben wir haben viel gesprochen mit mit
mit NGOs im Vorfeld und einige sind do
nicht gekommen ja auch wegen der
menschenrechtslager auch weil sie weil
sie sich da nicht wohl fühlen und auch
wegen der Kosten klar um ihre Sicherheit
fürchten
die hercherha nicht schcken K und
andererseits natürlich gab's auch die
die gesagt haben wir müssen aber hier
sein es ist 11 12 12 1 nach vielleicht
auch schon nach 12 ne ja das ist
schwierig zu ganz genau festzumachen
aber wir wollen da sein und trotzdem
irgendwie den Einfluss haben aber selbst
die die härtesten Kritiker sagen es gibt
halt nichts besseres als eine Kop genau
um die Welt zusammenzubringen und das
Problem zu lösen ja was ist denn die
Alternative was soll wir machen und und
ich glaube das ist dann auch sehr
überzeugend auch wenn das and nur in
Trippelschritten vorangeht und man sich
auch fragen muss klar jetzt 100.000
Menschen angeblich die hier extra
einfliegen das hat natürlich diesen da
kommt man schnell dies Gedanken ja
Klimawandel die Fliegen alle mitm
Flugzeug hin ja das ist schwierig aber
du hast es gesagt ne viele Treffen
werden hier da müssten 20 30 Flüge für
stattfinden weil hier einen auch die
Businesswelt aufeinander trifft die
politische Welt also das ist ein
bisschen aber so einfach ist auch nicht
weil das ist so der Gedanke hey wir
müssen zur ferde kurutsche zurück wir
dürfen nicht mehr fliegen wir dürfen
eigentlich gar nicht und das W wird man
hier nein ganz klar das wird man hier
nicht machen denn die sagen das ist
unser Reichtum und den lassen wir uns
nicht kaputt quatschen ja na ja aber ich
meine lassen wir uns den kaputt
quatschen also ich ich ich sehe selbst
wenn z.B Leute die sich für das Thema
engagieren zusammenkommen gibt's nicht
automatisch vegetarisches Essen ich
meine das müsste eigentlich ein Mast
sein das ist so einfach man braucht
nicht immer Fleisch und Fisch essen so
ganz einfache Dinge da tun wir uns noch
so mit so schwer mit die umzusetzen also
ich glaube wir haben nicht das Recht mit
dem erhobenen Zeigefinger der
Weltgemeinschaft zu sagen wo es lang
geht also ich glaube wir müssen uns
erstmal an die eigene Nase fassen in
Deutschland und da finde ich interessant
was was ist dein Eindruck du warst ja
auch
hier mit der deutschen Delegation in
Kontakt hast den Auftritt der deutschen
hier erlebt was war denn da dein
Eindruck ja also ich meine Deutschland
ist immer noch ein bisschen hat eine
Vorreiterrolle weil es ein sehr
großzügiger Geldgeber also der größte ne
oder einer der größten der dritt dritt
oder viertgrößte wenn man wenn man pro
wenn man insgesamt ich glaube pro Kopf
sind wir wahrscheinlich sogar mit der
Größe M das ist schon und viele Impulse
gehen aus ich glaube die Bundesregierung
ist egal welcher Couleur war immer
bemüht da eine vorrit der Rolle zu
spielen da ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen Skepsis jetzt nach dem Motto h
ja me man kriegt das schon mit irgendwie
mit Klimafinanzierung in Deutschland ist
jetzt nicht das Topthema aber man kriegt
mit okay da ist irgendwas da läuft was
nicht nicht richtig und und Deutschland
ist eine treibende Kraft auch in der EU
immer gewesen und da gab's schon
Befürchtungen der Bundeskanzler war hier
er hatte nicht viel im Gepäck er hat die
Reise mega verkürzt weil er erstmal
gucken muss ob mir den Haushalt für 2024
hinkriegen und das sind die Ausgaben für
Klimafinanzierung ja ein riesen Thema
aber natürlich auch alles andere also er
war da relativ
schmallippig er hat sich dann ganz am
Schluss es stand glaube ich noch nicht
mal im Redemanuskript was verschickt
wurde noch durchgerungen okay wir
sollten mal jetzt raus aus Kohle Öl Gas
da haben zumindest einige ein bisschen
aufgeatmet weil das ist ja auch
eigentlich die eup um die hier hart
gestritten wird denn eben in diesem
erdölstaat aber das war
kein das war jetzt kein Auftritt der die
Welt nach vorne gebracht hat das muss
man sagen ja aber Deutschland wird
sich wird sich hier nicht verabschieden
können das ist klar also wir spielen
eine Rolle wir sind noch eine der großen
Volkswirtschaften und wenn es um die
Finanzierung geht und noch alles dann
muss muss da vorangehen und
da hat man ja auch indem man den Deal
mit den Emiraten zusammen gemacht hat
sich ein bisschen auch mit in dieses ne
Boot setzen lassen ja okay wir sind noch
wichtig und wir wir wir machen wir
machen das
aber auf der anderen Seite war es
natürlich auch wenig Geld ja 100
Millionen kostet eine haben wir am Abend
den oton eingeholt kostet eine Insel im
Pazifik ein Dorf Umpflanzen kostet 100
Millionen ich meine so P mal Daumen das
wird nicht helfen
auf der anderen Seite hat natürlich ein
Präzedenzfall gesetzt dass wir sozusagen
jetzt vielleicht aus Saudiarabien Katar
die China also all die Singapur all die
Staaten die zu Geld gekommen sind eben
auch
ja vielleicht mal zahlen lassen und das
ist vielleicht der positive outlook wir
haben etwas erreicht hier schon es wird
schon was erreicht auf dieser
Klimakonferenz Deutschland hat da
mitgewirkt
und ja und es sind noch zwei Wochen Zeit
und es wird hart gerungen natürlich um
das große Ziel Ausstieg aus fossilen aus
Öl Kohle Gas und das sieht nicht gut aus
aber so eine Kopp hat seine eigenen
Gesetze und ich denke allein deshalb
lohnt es sich weiter drüber zu reden wir
werden das hoffentlich auch tun danke
für die Aufmerksamkeit und ich glaube
auch wenn es immer schwierig ist weil
wir immer sehr ins Negative gehen immer
dahin wo es weh tut das ist die Aufgabe
von Journalistinnen von Journalisten
aber es gibt auch viel positive und das
muss auch rausgestellt werden also die
Hoffnung stirbt wie immer
zuletzt